dude you came out and that play burned
this it was like you know it was already
a good play you didn't come on I felt
for like the first 10 minutes and when
your character comes in I thinkig he was
hammered or whatever he's just an
erratic crazy [__] person and you
came in and it was just like electri the
whole thing just it just was flying
after that and I'm not you know I'm a
comedian so like I'm going to Broadway
and we have like I think we
confuse you know cats with everything
else on Broadway so we just think it's
going to be like oh my God I had a dream
oh no how am I going to lie to this guy
afterwards and be like oh yeah that was
that was that was fantastic I got I got
my little cat's doll here and uh I I now
I want to be on the great white way I
would